but we begin tonight a bombshell new
report from just thenews.com
editor-in-chief John Solomon now
confirmed by Fox News quote that Federal
prosecutors have notified Donald Trump
that he is a criminal Target and likely
to be indicted imminently in a probe
into alleged classified documents I
guess Hillary's right around the corner
uh and not not far behind her as Joe
Biden now this after Trump's legal
defense team reportedly asked the doj to
delay the looming indictment because of
allegations serious ones that a senior
prosecutor tried to sway witness
testimony by discussing a federal
judgeship now that allegation is still
pending before a federal judge now still
the doj Apparently declined any kind of
delay and will be moving forward at a
rapid Pace in contrast they've had
Hunter Biden's laptop from hell since
December of 2019 and that probe has been
stalled five long years but they call
that equal justice an equal application
of our laws at least in this you know
psycho you know dual justice system we
now have but in a blatant attempt to
keep up with appearances Hunter now will
reportedly be indicted around the same
time as former president Trump let me
just stop right here
Hunter mark my words will likely not
face any of the serious charges nothing
to do with the investigations of Jim
Comer in the house oversight committee
uh definitely nothing that will
implicate pops who he has to give half
of his income to and pay his home repair
bills or as others refer to him as the
big guy getting his 10 percent uh this
will be nothing other than a show
indictment to cover their overtly
political never-ending persecution of
any and all things Donald J trump it
appears the doj has three goals one get
Trump as soon as possible prevent him
from becoming president to protect Joe
Biden at all costs and three try to save
face by using poor old Hunter the crack
addict who does portraits of a crack
addict and sells them for astronomical
amount of money for painting by numbers
I've never seen money like that for that
but they'll use him as a minor sacrifice
official lamb to justify going after
Trump so now the question is when can we
expect these looming indictments hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else